يا فهد فهد امس ما نتابع مباراه المغرب
كان يرى ان اللون الاحمر هو الطاغي اللون
الاحمر والاخضر يعني كان الجمهور مغربي كل
العرب جاؤوا من كل بقاع الارض من كل الدول
العربيه ليشجع منتخب المغرب امام فرنسا
يوم امس كيف كانت الاجواء ما بعد المباراه
والنتيجه
في الرباط في المغرب كان اللون الاحمر في
كل مكان حضر الجميع بتذكرها وبدون تذكره
الملعب كان مكتر تماما استاذ البيت
جميعا طبعا من غادر من المغرب لم يصل هنا
ولم يغادر بالطائره الا كان معه وتذكره
يعني امس وصل اخر اربع طائرات وصلت صباح
الامس اتجهوا فورا الى الملعب لكن دول
مجاوره المغاربه اللي همم موجودين هنا في
الدوحه كان كثير يعمل بالحصول على التذكره
حتى شاهدنا بعض
المواطنين المغاربه او المتعطفين يبكون
قبل همم قبل المباراه لعدم الحصول على
التذكره فكان يوم عاطفي في الكل تعاطف
الكل حتى لم يزعل من نتيجه المباراه كامله
مقدمه المنتخب المغربي همم اللي في الملعب
ضلوا بعد المباراه وحيون اللعيبه على
الانجاز نادين صباح مختلف راح نتجول معك
في اقدم قاعده يسمونها قاعده او مقهى في
الدوحه
ونسال المتابعين هنا عن شعورهم وانطباعهم
عن انجاز المنتخب المغربي هذه قهوه نعمه
وسلامه
هذا اللي العم ابو فرج اقدم واحد في
هالقعده من 20 سنه وهو جلسه نفس الجلسه
هذا عمنا
بقول لك هارد لك هزيمه المغرب امس والله
شوف
قول لي انا قول حق العرب
المنتخب
حلوه بس قدر الله وما شاء فعل فرنسا
نادين الكل فخور بندخل مغربي هذا العام
ابو فرج السعيد جدا الكل رافع راسه يا
خساره ولكن ليس خساره الاهم الاهم تحققوا
المنتخب المغربي
بالوصول للاربعه الكبار في كاس العالم انت
يعني عزمتني على الفطور انا كان بودي اصلا
اكون مكانك هيك منه بريحك بالصوت وبعيش
اجواء الساعات الحاسمه من كاس العالم شو
رايك
خلاص مواقف موافق تم تم انا جاهز تذكره
المباراه جاهزه هذه
واكيد فهد احنا بنشير اذا اذا انا مش
غلطانه ذكرني انه انت ارجنتيني بنتياز
ارجنتيني بامتياز انا اللي بعرفوا
طبعا الارجنتيني
لانه كان عندي احساس انه المغرب حيغادر
ولا كنت انا مغربي قلبا وقالبا لكن الان
لا انام على الارجنتين وان شاء الله الكاس
يرفعوا ميسي باذن الله يوم الاحد ان شاء
الله طيب هذه امنياتك في اماني اخرى لفراق
اخرى ونشكرك جزيل الشكر مراسل صباح
العربيه فهد الشهري من الدوحه شكرا ان شاء
الله
يا رب
طيب اذا كانت هذه هي الاجواء في سوق الان
ولحظنا يعني الساعه الان مبكرا 8:30 صباحا
والاجواء يعني نشطه